je voudrais tout d'abord vous faire
partager une conviction de femmes
je m'excuse de le faire devant cette
assemblée presque exclusivement composée
d'hommes aucune femme ne recourt de
gaieté de coeur à l'avortement
[Musique]
au lendemain de la première guerre
mondiale la france doit être repeupler
alors en 1920 les députés uniquement des
hommes trouvent la solution
une loi qui interdit tout bonnement
l'avortement et la contraception 50 ans
et un baby boom plus tard et malgré la
sévérité des peines encourues on
constate que 1920 n'est pas appliquée et
non n'est pas applicable non plus elle
est bafouée et voilà et qui est toujours
mauvais pour un état de conserver dans
sa réalisation
des textes qui sont inappliqué
évidemment tout le monde n'est pas de
cet avis je suis contre l'avortement
parce que l'avortement c'est un échec et
le constat d'un échec
je pense que la vie est une chose belle
je pense que rien est beau comme un
enfant ça c'est l'argument des opposants
et pour les défenseurs du progrès ça
ressemble à ça ce que nous proposons sur
s'ordonne autour de deux idées
la première c'est évidemment la priorité
à la contraception l'avortement c'est
toujours un pis-aller et nous
considérons que l'avortement doivent
être libres parce que le choix de la
naissance est un acte conscient pour
nous respecter la vie ça consiste à
choisir le moment on veut donner la vie
à un enfant à l'époque on estime à 300
mille le nombre de femmes qui se font
avorter chaque année est beaucoup trop
en gardent des séquelles voir perdre la
vie elle est atteinte des septicémies
c'est à dire d'une infection généralisée
très grave et autrefois régulièrement
mortel à la suite d'un avortement mal
fait il faut alors faire comprendre que
l'avortement n'est pas une solution de
confort ou de facilité mais un véritable
enjeu en 1972 a lieu le procès de
bobigny qui est devenu un symbole de ce
débat le procès lui même quel qu'ait été
le jus
le procès lui-même a marqué un pas
irréversible
michel chevalier est accusé avec trois
autres femmes de s'être rendue complice
de l'avortement de sa fille de 16 ans
enceinte à la suite d'un viol m halimi
réussi à faire acquitter sa cliente pour
la première fois dans l'histoire c'est
formidable les juges enfin pris leurs
responsabilités ils ont ils connaissance
des lois qu'elle était plus applicable
c'est alors une certitude la loi doit
changer et c'est simone veil alors
ministre de la santé qui aura la lourde
charge de présenter le texte de loi
je crois qu'on a oublié aujourd'hui les
jeunes ne savent pas est tant mieux ce
que c'était c'était vraiment un problème
très très très angoissant pour beaucoup
de femmes le débat qui a précédé le vote
de la loi a également été ponctuée par
des attaques violentes parfois même
absolument sordide alors simone veil
ayant survécu aux camps de concentration
le parallèle était carrément nauséabond
[Applaudissements]
mais je souhaite c'est que ce sont eux
sont dégagés et que j'en ai le débat est
alors extrêmement tendu la population
est divisée et tout le monde a un avis
sur la question
même si tout le monde n'est pas concerné
pendant une jeune fille de 16 ans au 17
ans est enceinte et ce qu'elle pourrait
se faire avorter ce genre oh non parce
qu'après ça va être
on ne s'en sort plus quoi penser qu'il y
aurait des as
oui ce sera la porte ouvert portes
ouvertes à quoi à tous les abus à tout
dire ah bon on peut y aller
tranquillement puisqu'on aura toujours
la porte de secours ce qui était tout de
même très désagréable dans le débat
c'est la façon dont il a été alors
faussé par des mouvements d'opinion
à l'extérieur il faut alors faire
comprendre que l'avortement est un
véritable problème qui se doit d'être
dépénaliser pour pouvoir être contrôlés
faire comprendre également les raisons
qui poussent certaines femmes à
interrompre leur grossesse mariah pas
encore terminé son secondaire et je
travaille je peux pas jeune mariée j'ai
eu un bébé un petit peu trop tôt à mon
avis est que j'aimerais en avoir dans
plusieurs elle dira pas tout de suite
tout de suite après il dit pour moi
l'avortement parce que une femme
juliette le premier besoin quelques et
l'a6 et de seul avis et c'est de la vie
son corps de temps levées toutes les
traces toutes les marques encore qualité
qui reste sur elle et puis moi quand
j'ai appris que j'étais en 5 c 4
le 5 avril 1971 343 femmes lancent
l'appel des 343 et clame un million de
femmes se font avorter chaque année je
déclare que je suis l'une d'elles je me
demande si cette loi aurait eu lieu ce
n'est pas commencé par signer le
manifeste des 343 après quelques fois
des 343 [ __ ] est manifeste nous nous
disions que dans notre vie nous étions
toutes faites avortées pendant que le
texte de loi se prépare le débat devient
nationale élus locaux nous n'acceptons
pas ce qui se prépare visiblement ils
sont contre mais nous pensons pas que la
solution soit les permis légal des tués
les arguments des anti ivg ramène
souvent le débat autour de la question
de la vie à venir sans prendre en compte
celle de la mère et des difficultés
qu'elle peut rencontrer comme à
l'avortement de suite à c'est absolument
incroyable enfin que sont les hommes qui
font les lois parce que s'il leur arrive
est quelquefois d'avoir les problèmes
des femmes et comprendrait plus
facilement qu'il faut absolument que ce
problème se règle très rapide
alors c'est avec autant de finesse que
d'intelligence que simone veil va
présenter son projet à l'assemblée
je voudrais tout d'abord vous faire
partager une conviction de femmes
je m'excuse de le faire devant cette
assemblée presque exclusivement composée
d'hommes
aucune femme ne recourt de gaieté de
coeur à l'avortement aucune
jamais je le dis avec toute ma
conviction
l'avortement doit rester l'exception
l'ultime recours pour des situations
sans issue ça c'est pour ceux qui
pensent que certaines avortent pour le
fun c'est toujours un drame
cela restera toujours un drame et bien
sûr derrière cette loi il y à des femmes
leur intégrité physique et psychologique
et parfois leur vie actuellement
celles qui se trouvent dans cette
situation de détresse qui s'en préoccupe
puis elle va interroger les opposants à
la loi sur leur jugement face à une
réalité bien plus amère parmi ceux qui
combattent aujourd'hui une éventuelle
modification de la loi répressive
combien sont ils ceux qui se sont
préoccupés d'aider ces femmes dans leur
détresse
combien sont ils ceux qui au delà de ce
qu'il juge comme une faute ont su
manifester aux jeunes mères célibataires
la compréhension et l'appui moral dont
elle avait un si grand besoin
la loi veil du 15 janvier 1975 autorise
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
un texte provisoire et votez pour cinq
ans le vote définitif aura lieu en 1979
et l'agent senti que au delà du sujet il
y avait une femme qui était seul au lieu
de ces hommes qui étaient d'une
une agressivité d'une oppression d'une
je tirais d'une vulgarité vis-à-vis de
la femme il avait l'impression que
c'était on leur arrache elle pouvoir le
pouvoir politique mais aussi on les
atteignait dans l'eure dans leur
virilité dans leur sexualité
aujourd'hui en france il existe toujours
des mouvements qui veulent limiter voire
interdire les vg et l'accès réel des
femmes y est très inégale selon les
territoires et encore sous tendu de bien
trop de jugement au planning familial du
département personne ne décroche et sur
place on trouve porte close
certaines femmes se trouvent donc livrée
à elle-même et manque d'information à
l'international la situation diffère
selon les pays
par exemple l'irlande progresse sur la
question tandis que l'argentine y est
toujours opposée et que l'espagne l'a
récemment remise en cause
nous devons soutenir les femmes pour que
l'avortement leur reste accessible la
société quels que soient son
développement économique où le régime
politique qui la gouverne a encore du
mal à concéder aux femmes la liberté de
décider si elles veulent ou non
poursuivre une grossesse
et pour citer simone de beauvoir
n'oubliez jamais qu'il suffira d'une
crise politique économique ou religieuse
pour que les droits des femmes soient
remis en question ces droits ne sont
jamais à qui vous devez rester vigilante
votre vie durant
[Musique]